foreign
James is with us in Chicago hi James
what's up
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help I'm so I'm selling my
current home and I'm scheduled to close
this month actually
um I'm also getting married in the next
month and building a home yeah and
you're building a home
yep at the same time good Lord lots of
Life yeah so we're also building a home
in the Southeast at the same time which
will be where we'll be starting our
family so we're actually waiting for
that to finish up before we move
um and then but so what I'm trying to
figure out is between my savings and the
profit from the current place that I'm
selling I'm trying to determine how much
I should put down on the new home
because I have quite a bit and I'm kind
of trying to go back and forth between
some of the things you say and throwing
as much as I can at the house and trying
to make that debt free as soon as
possible or taking some of that money
and putting it with my financial advisor
for them to invest it
yes well here's the thing I mean so you
already told me what I'm gonna say
[Laughter]
no it's not no there's no it's not no
it's not you know exactly what we say
you were very clear on that so all
you've got to decide James is which of
these methods you think has the highest
probability of Building Wealth
okay
getting your getting your house paid off
as soon as possible or borrowing on your
house to place the money with your tax
with your financial advisor
because effectively by not putting the
money down on the house you have
borrowed on the house
to put the money with the financial
advisor you understand that right
correct and so if you had a paid for
house would you go borrow on it to put
money with your financial advisor
because that's so smart that you're
going to get rich that way
obviously
you know I don't think that
yeah and to your point I think my point
of view is I I think that
psychologically being debt free as soon
as possible I think if you take the
number of years I'll probably say 10
years from now I think the same amount
of money probably goes into the market
just once I'm as close to being debt
free that I'll be much more aggressive
um but I'll still have probably a 250
the three hundred thousand dollar
mortgage that I'll have to pay off
because it's it's not a cheap house
let's put it that way but uh how old are
you but but
uh 30. okay well I mean obviously James
you can do whatever you want you're like
a 30 year old man
let me tell you let me tell you that
you're wrong
and you called here to ask and so the
data tells us when we talk to
millionaires we talk to 10 167 of them
when we did detailed in-depth research
the larger study a Millionaire's ever
done in North America the number of
millionaires that we talked to that said
the reason I'm a millionaire is I
borrowed as much as I could on my house
I limited how much I put down on my
house so that I could put the money with
my financial advisor in the market
sooner and I carried a mortgage was the
net essence of this so that I had more
money in the market and that money and
the market and leveraging and using my
personal residence as a way to get rich
caused me to become a millionaire the
number of millionaires that said that
was precisely zero James
sure and here's my promise here's my
promise so you go with your plan or you
go with theirs my promise to you James
is this you're the guy who sold the
house got married and tried to build a
house in the same month
good for you
you're a hustler you always have a
scheme and you always got a plan and a
plan and then a plan on top of that plan
that money that you think is going to be
in the market in 10 years won't because
your buddy in your new place will have
talked you into real estate properties
and you own a couple of duplexes because
you sell it on Instagram that money
won't be there
pay your house off and be free my
brother and then you can invest as
whatever you want
looking for a shortcut be free the
fastest way to get rich quick is don't